[Music]
covet 19 has plunged us into a virtual
world
we have had to change how we do
everything
classes work awkward happy hours
dating oh wait um i forgot to turn
on my virtual background let me fix that
did not want to show you guys my bed
and it's not turning us we're just gonna
run with it
okay yes but where was it we've had to
change how we do everything
communication is no different virtual
communication requires different skills
and tips and techniques but luckily it
is something that we can learn
how to do effective and my battery is
done
one sec while i grab my charger sorry
did not mean to show you my pajamas
uh did not think i would be getting up
but anyway
you can learn how to be an effective
virtual communicator the only things
that take afternoon
can you can you turn that off i'm kind
of in the middle of our finals
we are supposed to be here to help
people to be more effective
communicating virtually you're not doing
that
yeah you're kind of right anderson i
wish there was a way where i could learn
to be a better virtual communicator
i actually think we can help we anderson
are you saying that you and mario
and jorge surveyed our class and looked
things up on the internet to teach me
how to be
a better virtual communicator that is so
awesome please tell me what should i be
doing
how do i fix that fix my setup and think
about my environment
and how do i better use my technology
as neha introduced we're here to help
you to become more effective
communicating
virtually i'm going to start by talking
about the things you should do before
and during the delivery of your virtual
presentation
before you start delivering your
presentation consider
carefully choosing a place where you can
stay throughout
you don't want to be running your wallet
with your computer with the video on
nor interrupting the meeting in order
for you to change places
second it is very important to dress
properly
if you're having a business meeting or
having
a business presentation dress
professionally
considering wearing the same clothes you
would as if you were meeting your
audience or giving your presentation in
person
it all it is also important to dress
comfortably
if you're constantly moving around
because you're uncomfortable
your audience might perceive you as
being uncertain or insecure about the
topic you're presenting
and finally but not less important dress
entirely i know what you guys are
expecting here
but i'm not showing you a picture of
jorge and his boxers
come on guys now it's time for action
when you start delivering your virtual
presentation position yourself
in a way that your frame and your image
looks natural to your audience
and again niha this is not a good
example
a few things to consider are keep your
eyes at the same height of the camera
leave a few inches of space between your
head and the upper part of the video
and make sure that your shoulders fit
into the framing
this is naturally the normal field of
vision you would have
if you were interacting or talking to
someone either i
and in an in-person setting second
stand your ground no matter if you are
standing up
or delivering your presentation sitting
down position
your two feet firmly on the ground this
will not only make you look
more confident to your audience
preventing you from swaying back and
forth
but it will also help you reduce the
levels of anxiety you might be
experiencing
it is also a good practice to try to
avoid when possible
the use of swivel chairs third
be mindful of the gestures and their
distance to the camera
since they can be amplified the closer
you get to the camera
and that might seem distracting to your
audience
and finally look at the people you're
talking to
in the eye the way to do that in a
virtual environment
is by looking at the camera a few things
can help you do that
we have a natural tendency at looking at
ourselves while we are presenting
and a good practice jorge i know this is
hard but it is to hide yourself view
where you're presenting on zoom
it is also useful to paste something
nearby your camera
such that it catches your attention and
your
eye looks at the camera in the direction
of your audience
now guys that you already know what to
do when presenting in a virtual
environment
i'm gonna pass it over to mario to talk
about the environment
thank you anderson great tips now
i'm gonna give you best practices on how
to make your setup
or your environment first of all
we're going to tackle the camera and the
mig as these are key elements to deliver
your presentation
on the camera you want to make sure that
there's arm's length distance between
the screen and yourself
this will create a bear frame
furthermore
you want to be center on the screen as
anderson said you don't want to be
leaning left
or want to be leaning right finally
on that aspect show a little bit of your
upper body
don't be the person that shows only his
or her face
on the mic just make sure that the audio
is set up correctly
either your headset or the speakers of
the computer
be like neja in this picture she's doing
great
in the in that instance however
don't be like this guy
next it's on your room this is very easy
to mess up
so make sure your room is clean and it's
organized respect your audience and
respect yourself
don't be like anderson for example
then also make sure that there are no
surprises
so when you're gonna give a presentation
make your roommates or your family aware
that you're gonna deliver this
presentation
you don't want any surprises or noises
in the background
don't be like jorge
furthermore leverage your backgrounds
there you can use your backgrounds in
your favor when delivering your
presentation
if you want to be warm and welcoming
don't use a background and invite them
into your home or into your office
however if you're feeling loyal use your
company logo and really inspire your
employees
also if you're having a messy room as
anderson just
use any background almost any will do
next lights and shadows this is very
straightforward
but it's good to make it right you want
to make sure
that you're trying for a bright room
with lots of natural lighting
and lots of windows however if this is
not available
just make sure to turn on the lights as
many as possible
again don't beat this guy
and finally deliver your message from a
comfortable place
whether that's in a desk stand-up desk
or a table
you want to respect your audience and
you want to avoid presenting from the
better the floor
like neha don't be like neha in this
scenario in other scenarios you can be
like
okay so now we're we're moving on to the
tech piece
and okay will help us on that
really guys really
the tech guide explained the technology
come on guys this is such a cliche
anyway um let me tell you something
soon meetings are like vaccines
they need a lot of testing before you
get to deliver them
but what do we need to test
first of all test your technology
make sure that your audio and your video
is correctly working today's tools
allows us to visually test that our
speaker and our microphone
are correctly working second
is that your wi-fi is correctly working
too
i know i know when you want to watch
breaking bad
you have always great internet but when
there is a chance that you might get
cold call
suddenly your internet dies avoid that
by first trying to see if you have a
good speed on your internet
for example you can go to speedtest.net
and see how fast is it a good rule of
thumb is that
you will need 3 megabits per second in
order to be able to
send and receive high definition video
also be sure that you have good battery
that runs through the whole meeting
video conferencing takes a lot of
resources from the computer
and actually it will only last for one
third of what it's budgeted
so for example if you have battery that
says that will run for one hour
it will normally run for only 20 minutes
next you need to check the apps
technology in these apps
nowadays there are a lot of ways to
engage with your audience there's chat
there is polls there is share screen and
so on
be sure that you familiarize with these
tools
and be sure that you set expectations
right at the beginning of the meeting
of when and how you want your audience
to engage
and last you will also need to
prepare for faith
it might be that sometimes your device
just dies and then it's very it's
a great tool to have a second device
available so that you are always
prepared for the unexpected
and you can you can come back from your
from for to the meeting almost without
hesitation
what do you think we have do you think
that we have
covered everything do you think that we
can do a good job now
anderson mario jorge this has been so
helpful
i think i know how to be a more
effective virtual communicator
so let's take it again from the top
covid has thrown us into a virtual
environment and we've had to change how
we do everything
whether it's classes and work or whether
that's awkward happy hours in dating
we can all learn how to be effective
virtual communicators
we can think about what we do our setup
and environment
and our technology as we've learned
today
at the end of the day we can change
lives
change organizations and change the
world
by using communication as a superpower
from the comfort
of our own bedrooms thank you
[Music]